how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe
where are all the trailers for marvel
studios that's what everybody wants to
know right now we are patiently and
impatiently awaiting the falcon and the
winter soldier trailer the one division
trailer
a new black widow trailer and the
eternals trailer
and the question is are we going to be
getting them anytime
soon well we have a couple of slight
updates today that tell us a little bit
about when we can expect the eternals
trailer especially since marvel studios
seems to be opened back up in production
on many of their shows have started
again or are starting this week
even kumail nanjiani who was going to
play kingo
in the eternals had some things to say
this morning
about the teaser trailer so we'll break
it all down in this video and we'll
break down
marvel studios this process for
releasing trailers
which ones we can expect to come first
and when to expect the eternals trailer
but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest
mcu news and this week we're giving away
a gladiator hulk funko pop all you got
to do to enter subscribe like this video
and leave a comment down below
so to start it off and this is relevant
to the eternals trailer it looks like
marvel studios is
resuming production this week on the
falcon and the winter soldier
now this was reported last week by
charles murphy he said that production
should resume within the next two weeks
and now thanks to the instagram account
atlanta filming who has leaked
many different things from the set of
all marvel studios productions filming
in atlanta we can see that it does in
fact look like marvel studios is
resuming production
as there is a lot of equipment on a set
for something so their sets back
up where they were filming the falcon
and the winter soldier before and
there's equipment there now so it looks
like they're going to resume production
soon
now we'll come back to this because it
does affect the eternals teaser trailer
release
but right now let's talk about what
kumail najiyani had to say yesterday or
early this morning depending on where
you live he sent out a tweet that said
working with chloe has been one of the
most thrilling and satisfying
experiences of my career
chloe of course being the director of
the eternals i'm excited to see her
films for decades to come
and grateful i get to be a small part of
one of them
a visionary and true filmmaker then he
links a article but what's really
interesting
is the replies that he give to people
who replied to his tweet
one person said please tell marvel to
release the teaser and he replied
i will i don't know if they'll listen to
me another said
some maternals news will take it and he
said i know there isn't much
news yet i'm in the dark too trust me i
can't wait for it whenever it comes
and then somebody specifically asked
when is the trailer dropping
king where literally starved and he said
i don't know
i'm starved too believe me and then
finally somebody said where is the
trailer poster news and he said i
honestly
don't know waiting just like everyone
else impatiently
now some people may think that he
actually does know he just has to say
that he doesn't but here's the true
reality he most likely doesn't know
because the eternal's trailer depends on
a lot of other factors that have to
happen before
it gets released we have to remember
that the mcu is an order
every event in one movie or show now
affects events and the others to come
simply put the black widow movie has to
be released in theaters or on video on
demand if that's what they decide to do
and the falcon and the winter soldier
teaser has to happen first
before the eternals teaser comes out the
eternals trailer is pretty much waiting
for black widow because they're going to
release the trailer
when black widow hits the theaters but
right now unfortunately even marvel
studios doesn't know if black widow is
going to keep its november release date
and if it's going to be in theaters or
video on demand
so he is telling the truth when he says
that there isn't any news and he doesn't
know when the teaser is going to drop
but we do know that it's waiting on
black widow and the falcon and the
winter soldier and the good news is that
the falcon and the winter soldier is
starting back up again
and we're now less than two months away
from black widow's theatrical release
date and if they're going to postpone it
they'll do it within the next month
so we should know pretty soon because if
it does keep its theatrical release date
we can expect the eternals teaser to
come with it because that'll also mean
that the falcon and the winter soldier
should be done
filming and editing by then so
everything should be on track if black
widow keeps its november 6th theatrical
release date so sit tight we won't have
to wait that much longer for some
official news and hopefully black widow
keeps its release date but in the
meantime let me know what you'd like to
see
happen in the eternals film let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest mcu
news you can follow me on instagram and
twitter for more news updates and
giveaways and as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof
you